the bicycle is an essential means of
transportation in today's cities and
Berlin is no exception
bikes are often seen as a way of
bypassing traffic jams ebikes with
electric motors have been growing in
popularity for years more than 3 million
ebikes are already on the road in
Germany almost every bicycle type also
has a motorized version but this ebike
is different it was designed by matthias
Prada he wanted to build an electrically
powered bike that's both efficient and
sustainable he used locally sourced ash
wood and hid all the technical
components the result is an ultra-modern
bike with a retro look big difference is
that the motor and battery together
weigh a total of 3.5 kilos we have the
motor and battery all in one that means
there are no cables on this bike but why
did he opt for wood as the main material
aim was to manufacture a bikes that are
neutral in co2 and for that the use of
wood is pretty obvious trees absorb
carbon dioxide and while they're growing
already gave us a plus before we even
started we did have to add some metal
parts but at least we have a relatively
neutral co2 balance overall you have a
lot you've also vulnerable on
rota has won a number of awards for his
invention including the green product
award his is the first wooden ebike
ready for serial production but if you
want one you'll have to dig deep they
sell for 4,500 euros apiece the trend
toward retro bikes remains strong these
classic bicycle models have sleek
tubular steel frames and simple
technology retro bike fans don't see
their of two-wheelers as just a way to
get around or get exercise but as a
status symbol complete with custom
accessories this is a very beautiful
bicycle from the Netherlands it's
specifically designed for young people
for example by the various colors like
the red brake and shift cubes the red is
reflected in the black paint and we have
nicely coordinated leather grips on the
handlebars so is the center it's also
made of a very strong leather it's a
really harmonious overall concept also
gaining in prestige especially in the
major cities are vintage bikes
unlike retro bikes which revive past
styles these genuinely are old what's
important for Sven Alava Vin de Hawk is
the design and the stories his bikes
have to tell as well as the riding
experience its Infante a bike of this
quality new would be in an entirely
different price bracket these have
already been produced so nothing has to
be made from scratch these bikes still
ride quite well and it'll be ashamed
just leave it all standing around
renting bikes has also become more
trendy when Berlin startup called list
and ride has developed a platform that
allows people to rent out their bikes
when they're not using them they call
their idea Airbnb for cyclists what you
see nowadays is that the sharing economy
is booming technology whether it's it's
a desktop or mobile people just search
and look and are willing to book online
and that's basically the business
component of things and and that's where
we said hey why don't we go after our
passion and and yeah make make it happen
for people that want to have great bikes
any place anywhere the customer selects
their desired bike using the list and
ride app or website and then collect it
from the owner the company charges a fee
for the service for some it's also a
great opportunity to try out a bike
they're interested in but wouldn't
necessarily buy themselves but one
thing's for sure in Germany as elsewhere
in Europe bicycles are definitely a
trendy way to travel